after weeks of relative calm Sirens once
again warn of danger in the Skies over
Ukraine
waves of Russian Rockets missiles and
drones fired from the air Land and Sea
had ukrainians running for cover in
cities across the country
children but
the energy Ministry ordered power
shutdowns all over the country after
missiles hit energy grid points in at
least six regions here in kievair
defense systems shot down a missile
before it could hit its intended target
there was some debris damage in this
neighborhood but it is a far cry from
destruction in other parts of the
country
one official from the eastern city of
kharkiv described it as the largest
barrage since the Russian invasion began
nearly a year ago
in the South people in zapparisha pick
through their destroyed homes one
explosion so powerful it tossed a car
onto the roof of a house
they are not humans that's how I put it
I don't know what the Russians are
thinking about when they are doing this
when they press the buttons and shell
civilians they are very well aware that
they are firing at us they know it it's
horrible
Friday's wave of attacks will reinforce
Ukraine's latest plea to allies for
fighter jets and longer range missiles
to help Kiev take back its airspace it
will also test the resolve of
neighboring countries Zain basavi Al
Jazeera Kiev